[Música]
después de que se acordaran a los
protocolos de tránsito en el acuerdo
para la exportación segura de granos y
cereales de los puertos ucranianos
naciones unidas- anticipa un gran
aumento en los barcos que buscan
transportar estos alimentos a través del
mar negro con una meta de 2 a 5 millones
de toneladas por mes algo necesario
teniendo en cuenta las más de 20
millones de toneladas represadas y la
nueva cosecha que corre el riesgo de no
tener dónde será almacenada el objetivo
del acuerdo es ayudar a aliviar la
crisis alimentaria mundial que según
naciones unidas empeoró con la guerra
este acuerdo cumplirá el próximo 22 de
agosto un mes desde su firma y hasta hoy
se está lejos de cumplir esta meta de 2
a 5 millones de toneladas de granos
exportadas por mes salvamos entonces a
nuestra segunda invitada del día es la
doctora a nivel contreras a suárez
analista de asuntos globales y coordina
ahora la licenciatura de negocios
globales de la universidad
iberoamericana de ciudad de mexico ariel
un gusto tenerla nuevamente con nosotros
en directo américa de france 24 buena
mañana de miércoles le pregunto si se
podrá cumplir
esta meta hasta la fecha alrededor de
500 mil toneladas han sido exportadas y
la meta como ya lo estábamos adelantando
es de 2 a 5 millones por mes estamos muy
lejos no muy buenos dias rebolo un gusto
saludar y sin duda lo estás
puntualizando muy bien este acuerdo al
cual pues ya casi que se cumple un mes
que fue firmado y establece este
objetivo de aproximadamente 5 toneladas
por mes pero si consideramos que son
casi más o menos 20 mil millones de
toneladas las que están paradas en
ucrania por más que se quiera aumentar
la capacidad de buques a través de tres
puertos que se lo des a él
este que se llama sierra works ya
también que se llama youzhny por más que
quieran aumentar el gran envío de buques
era raúl hay una capacidad limitada es
decir dependiendo del tamaño del buque
que los buque los buques graneleros
básicamente son cuatro tipos que van
desde las 30.000 hasta las 110 mil
toneladas por cada buque pues estamos
viendo que esto es un nuevo cuello un
nuevo cuello de botella no
el envío está muy lejos de la meta de
estas 5 millones de toneladas mensuales
porque también hay que considerar raúl
que hay grandes cantidades de toneladas
de trigo que ya se llama perder otras
que ya llenaron estos cilindros de
granos desde trigo maíz y soya y
entonces ahora lo importante sería qué
van a hacer para poder agilizar la
capacidad de carga tener una gran
cantidad de flota de buques graneleros
para que esto se pudiera acelerar porque
nos podemos perder de vista el baúl que
prácticamente
2.500 millones de personas en 89 países
en el mundo dependen de granos a nivel
que pasará precisamente con estos de 20
a 25 millones de toneladas digamos que
están represadas estos alimentos como ya
había usted bien lo dijo se están
dañando pero además también hay otro
agravante esta nueva cosecha ya han
recogido si no estoy mal a más de un
millón de toneladas de granos esta nueva
hecha los siglos en los puertos están ya
que no dan más para almacenar esta
cosecha cuán grave es la situación y por
qué entonces la comunidad internacional
no se aboca realmente a los puertos
ucranianos con más buques para seguir
sacando los entiendo además que no es
una operación humanitaria es una
operación netamente comercial por eso
los barcos están siendo pues
investigados no investigados como serán
inspeccionados de una manera exhaustiva
en estambul para pues mitigar estas
preocupaciones de moscú para que no se
filtren digamos armas que era la mayor
preocupación de que este acuerdo se
llevará a cabo entonces como que
complicaba el panorama pero que
realmente se puede hacer para para
además que no se vote esta estas
toneladas de alimentos
y yo creo que lo estás puntualizando muy
pertinentemente no osea pareciera que
esto es una trampa mortal donde por un
lado se firme el acuerdo están los
buques están los granos están los
compradores urgentemente esperando estas
toneladas de trigo pero al tener un
escenario de guerra al ser una zona de
conflicto y al tener ciertos candados
que así lo exigió rusia para que no se
generara que en lugar de que fueran
buques mercantes pudieran ser militares
entonces esto ralentiza mucho el proceso
raúl estamos viendo que estos corredores
marítimos desde hace meses ya la
organización marítima internacional
había solicitado que permitieran
liberarse porque había casi 400 buques
varados con personal con pocos alimentos
hoy este acuerdo llega en espera de que
pudiera ser una bocanada de oxígeno pero
estamos viendo que es mucho más lento y
entonces el comercio de los granos va a
empezar a entrar a una terapia intensiva
donde la demanda cada vez aumenta la
oferta existe pero está detenida y
entonces aquí ahora lo importante será
que las naciones unidas continúen
haciendo sus esfuerzos diplomáticos para
que la parte económica comercial pero de
seguridad alimentaria no pueda verse
todavía más vulnerable a lo que ya de
por si se ha visto afectada a la luz de
esta guerra y entonces ahora se le
tendrá que apostar más a tener más
personal en los buques que se acelera la
capacidad de descarga del grano hacia
estos buques graneleros y de igual
manera en los puertos receptores de irán
de turquía y de otros países del
mediterráneo tendrán también que
acelerar la capacidad de descarga para
que una vez que estos buques estén
vacíos regresen a los tres puertos de
ucrania y otra vez se repita la
operación estaremos viendo un escenario
muy parecido a lo que fue la crisis de
los chips semiconductores ya con sus
respectivas comparaciones porque esto se
trata de un alimento y aunque no es
inmediatamente pérez si es un elemento
que todos los granos que no mandó nada
más es el tema de cotizaciones en
espacio internacional son los precios se
han duplicado sino ahorita lo que se
trata es contener esta crisis de granos
por el tema de la seguridad alimentaria
en una gran cantidad de países son
varios puntos también a nivel un costo
económico enorme para ucrania que deja
de percibir digamos las ganancias de
estas exportaciones de granos además la
guerra en curso el objetivo de rusia de
digamos acercar marítima mente a ucrania
obviamente afecta logísticamente esas
exportaciones como bien lo estábamos
hablando y teniendo encuesta en cuenta
todo esto podría ucrania pasar de ser un
país exportador de alimentos a un país
importador de alimentos
me encanta tu pregunta raúl porque
estamos viendo que este escenario
cualquier país en tierra comienza a
tener déficits sobre todo en alimentos
cuando se nos puso a la atención que
ucrania es es el centro granero del
mundo pues ahí es donde entendimos la
importancia de que pudiera seguir
exportando estos granos pero también
rusia que pudiera seguir exportando los
fertilizantes porque si no pues no hay
cosechas en ninguna parte del mundo hoy
me parece que este epicentro que tú
destacas de ucrania que ahora se pudiera
convertir en el importador pues de hecho
prácticamente un país en guerra requiere
de los alimentos y la asistencia
humanitaria que reciban por parte del
exterior desde países
la comisión europea pero también por
parte de la cruz roja internacional así
que ucrania hoy y seguirá siendo el
epicentro de grandes batallas no sólo la
militar sino también de hambre